hello AI Enthusiast the Curious mind in
you has turned you up to let you explore
the ever so amazing world of AI and
natural language processing well why
shouldn't it after all chat GPT and AI
tools are all the r right now all of
them are based on the foundational
functioning of NLP in this video we will
discuss NLP in detail talking about the
awesome self
NLP professionals make along with
telling you exactly what skills you need
to join this league of high earning
professionals so hold on to your curious
heads and let's Jump Right In and just a
quick info for you if you want to
upskill yourself and master artificial
intelligence and machine learning and
natural language processing and land
your dream job or grow in your career
then you must explore simply learns
cohort of various a ml programs simply
line offers various certification and
post-graduate programs in colle
collaboration with some of the world's
leading universities like won Purdue
keltech I kpur and many more through our
courses you will gain knowledge and work
ready expertise in skills like
generative AI promt engineering
explainable AI machine learning
algorithms and over a dozen others and
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
in Top Tire product companies and
academicians from top universities after
completing these courses
thousands of Learners have transitioned
into an AI or ml role as a fresher or
moved onto a higher paying job role and
profile if you're passionate about
making your career in this field then
make sure to check out the link in the
pin comment and description box to find
anml program that fits your experience
and areas of Interest what is NLP
natural language processing NLP
constitutes a sector of artificial
intelligence focused on textual and
speech data this technology enables
machines to comprehend scrutinize and
handle human language extract valuable
information in the process now let's
understand who is an NLP engineer a
natural language processing engineer or
NLP engineer is a professional
responsible for crafting and
constructing computer systems that can
process assess and produce humanik
language NLP branches out into numerous
captive a in domains including semantic
analysis sentiment analysis face
recognition machine translation and
speech
recognition now the reach of NLP extends
across a diverse spectrum of
applications notably featuring virtual
assistance chat Bots sentiment analysis
customer service interactions and
language translation the task of NLP
Engineers involves erecting these
Innovative applications and seamlessly
embedding them into existing Frameworks
now the average salary of an NLP
engineer is 10 lakhs per anom in India
in us the annual wage of NLP Engineers
is about
$120,000 per an now let us understand
the skills required to become an NLP
engineer becoming a natural language
processing engineer entails the
acquisition of diverse set of skills and
knowledge some of these and Compass the
first one as Python Programming Mastery
of at least one programming language
such as python Java or C++ coupled with
solid grasp of data structures
algorithms and the principles of
software engineering is important next
is grasp of machine learning building a
strong foundation in machine learning
algorithms encompassing both supervised
and unsupervised learning is important
familiarity with Advanced Techniques
like convolution addal neural networks
or also known as CNN and recurrent
neural networks also known as rnns is
vital the third one being NLP techniques
cultivating a deep understanding of NLP
techniques which encompasses facets like
text preprocessing syntactic and
semantic analysis and the intricate
domain of sentiment
analysis fourth one is NLP libraries and
Frameworks navigate easily through the
NLP libraries and Frameworks such as the
natural language toolkit or nltk Spacey
Stanford core NLP and jesm harnessing
their capabilities to streamline your
NLP and device the fifth one is data
science Acumen developing a sound grasp
of data science principles and
compassing facets such as data
visualization statistical analysis and
the Art of data manipulation is
important armed with this multifaceted
skill set the you will be primed to
embark on a journey as an accomplished
NLP engineer who is ready to navigate
the complexities of natural language and
contribute to the exciting world of NLP
Innovations now the important point of
today's session that is the road map to
become an NLP engineer here is a
comprehensive professional strategy or
trajectory for those aspiring to become
Adept natural language processing
Engineers the first one is education
Foundation embark on your journey by
pursuing a degree in a pertinent field
such as computer science Linguistics or
artificial intelligence many
accomplished NLP Engineers hold Advanced
degrees either a master's or a PhD in
these domains next one is internship or
entry-level Ventures consider immersing
yourself in Practical experience through
internships or entry-level positions
within the industry these opportunities
not only equip you with Hands-On
expertise but also Aid in constructing a
robust portfolio moreover they
facilitate the establishment of valuable
professional connections next is skills
and knowledge acquisition develop a
comprehensive grasp of the essential
proficiencies requisites for an NLP
engineer this encompasses programming
progess machine learning Acumen NLP
techniques familiarity with pertinent
libraries and Frameworks proficiency and
data science and the owning of
communication and teamwork
competencies next is portfolio
development toate a diverse portfolio
teaming with projects that eliminate
your capabilities and expertise projects
like a sophisticated chat a sentiment
analysis tool or a language model can
substantiate your aptitude for solving
real world NLP challenges and validate
your skill set for potential employers
now the next one networking and
engage in conferences meetups and
Industry events to forge connections
with fellow NLP professionals this
affords opportunities to remain AB
breast of the latest developments in the
field and exposes you to an area of NLP
applications next is specialization
consideration Ponder the prospect of
specializing in a specific NLP realm be
it machine translation speech
recognition or conversational agents
this specialization not only def
differentiates you in the job market but
also enables you to attain expertise
within a particular niche in submission
the path towards becoming an NLP
engineer entails a fusion of educational
attainment hands-on experience and the
Mastery of an Eclectic area of skills
and knowledge to means now we will
discuss the applications of NLP natural
language processing both an extensive
area of applications extending well
beyond the following 10 examples we have
chat Bots intelligent replies on chatbot
platform which as email or LinkedIn
virtual assistance in Customer Care
Services spelling check and grammar
correction in India the salary ranges
from 2.5 million rupees to 5 million
rupees however in us the salary ranges
between $60,000 to $90,000 per year
enter level NLP Engineers typically have
background in computer science
engineering or a related field and have
some experience with NLP but may not
have yet worked on large scale
Enterprise projects moving towards
mid-level NLP Engineers these Engineers
earn 5 million to 8 million rupees per
year however in United States they earn
between $90,000 to
$120,000 per year midlevel NLP Engineers
have few years of experience working on
NLP projects and are typically
comfortable working on both Technical
and business related aspects of NLP
projects they may have some leadership
responsibilities and are often
responsible for ensuring that NLP
projects are completed on time and to
spec next we have a senior level NLP
Engineers these Engineers earn up to 8
million rupees to 15 million rupees in
India per year however in United States
they earn between
$120,000 to
$165,000 per year senior level NLP
Engineers have extensive experience
working on Enterprise level NLP projects
and are often considered authorities in
NLP Technologies methods and tools they
may serve as subject matter experts lead
teams of Engineers and other NLP
professionals and be responsible for
ensuring the long-term success of NLP
projects and here we wrap up our video
and if you have any queries regarding
any Concept in this video feel free to
add it in the comment section below and
our experts will be happy to help you do
subscribe to Simply learn to stay
updated with new technology Trends and
thanks for watching staying ahead in
your your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here